she's an American who received an Oscar
nomination this year for playing British
he's an Australian who got a nomination
for playing American please welcome
Julianne Moore and Russell Crowe
gay folks hey Don tonight's nominees for
best achievement in art direction
brilliantly transport audiences to
another time in place from the England
of Queen Victoria to the New England
princes of Maine from a criminally
beautiful Venetian Palazzo to a
tyrannically accurate Siamese Palace to
a ghost town on the Hudson
these artists get every detail right to
suspend our disbelief here are the
nominees for Anna and the King art
direction by Luciano Regan set direction
by Ian Whitaker
with a side of house rules art direction
by David Rothman and set Direction
decoration by Beth Rubino
for Sleepy Hollow our direction by Rick
Heinrichs and set decoration by Peter
young for the talented mr. Ripley art
direction by Roy Walker and set
decoration by Bruno society at the
topsy-turvy art direction by Eve Stewart
and set decoration by Eve Stewart and
John Bush
and the Oscar goes to Rick Heinrich
Sleepy Hollow and Peter Young
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Rick Heinrichs
set set decorator extraordinaire Peter
Young was unable to come tonight and if
I read the rules correctly I got to take
home two of these as a result of that I
hope so anyway um I just hope you don't
mind if I brought this the teleprompter
doesn't work for me
I share this award with an artist whose
unique brilliance I got the glimpse
twenty years ago in a wickedly funny
short film about a demented dentist
director Tim Burton whose compelling
vision of Sleepy Hollow was the
inspiration we all keyed off of I also
share it with two gifted art directors
les Tompkins and John Dexter and three
wonderful art departments in London LA
and New York I'm grateful for the
support and the prodding of producer
Scott Rudin Adam Schroeder and Larry
Franco and the backing of Paramount
Pictures Sherry Lansing Michele Manning
and nan Morales and thanks for the for
the patience and love throughout of my
wife dawn and thank you to my parents
for having me thanks